[Applause]
good morning
it's my honor to welcome merrick garland
back to the department of justice
as the 86th attorney general of the
united states
i'd also like to recognize the attorney
general's wife
lynn his brother-in-law mitchell and his
nieces laura
and andrea in many respects
this is a welcome home ceremony for the
attorney general
before his appointment to the u.s court
of appeals for the district of columbia
circuit
he served with distinction in a number
of positions here at maine justice
in the district of columbia
i first met the attorney general
approximately 25 years ago
when he was the principal associate
deputy attorney general
i have always admired his intellect his
integrity
his commitment to public service and his
humility
he recognizes the traditions of the
department
and trusts and respects its career civil
servants
he sees his role as being the lawyer for
the people of the united states
and making decisions that are based on
the law
and the facts devoid of political
considerations
during his confirmation hearing a few
weeks ago attorney
attorney general garland said it is a
fitting time
to reaffirm that the role of the
attorney general
is to serve the rule of law and to
ensure equal justice under the law
as he further noted this is a moment too
for recognizing the employees of the
department and its law enforcement
agencies
and their commitment to serve the cause
of justice and protect the safety
of our communities this is an important
period
in the history of our venerated
institution and we are grateful to you
mr attorney general for your willingness
once again
to answer the call to duty we look
forward to continuing to serve in the
department of justice
under your leadership thank you very
much
thank you so much for those kind words
monty
as monty said we first met when i was
working for the deputy attorney general
monty was an assistant u.s attorney
initially a prosecutor and then a
supervisor of prosecutors
monte later jumped to the department's
offices that make everything work first
to the executive office for u s
attorneys
and then to the justice management
division
and for the past seven weeks monty has
ensured that the department continued to
work
and to honor its proud traditions during
the leadership transition between new
administrations
i'm deeply grateful
on january 7th of this year when the
president-elect announced his intention
to nominate me for attorney general
i spoke to the american people on
february 22nd
when my senate judiciary committee
hearing began
i spoke to the united states congress
today i want to speak to you
the more than 115 000 employees
of the united states department of
justice
now i had hoped to be standing before
more of you today
in this great hall but the circumstances
of the ongoing pandemic will not permit
it
that however is a small disappointment
compared to the hardships that many of
you have suffered
and the additional burdens you have born
as a consequence
of the pandemic i have to tell you that
when i walked in
the door of maine justice this morning
it really did feel like i was coming
home
i first walked into this building when i
was 26
years old i was here for a job interview
and i was awestruck this is a beautiful
hall
and this is a beautiful building built
in the midst of the great depression but
it was the ideal of
justice to which it is a monument
that was truly awe-inspiring everywhere
i looked there were serious people
pursuing the cause of justice i
i left the interview wanting the job
badly
the way i'm sure each of you felt after
your doj interview
the way we want everyone who interviews
at doj
to feel i know that was how i felt
every time i came back to interview for
another justice department position
and after leaving my first position for
private practice
i did come back many times to serve in a
variety of positions
both career and non-career
along the way i worked with doj
attorneys
agents and staff in every component of
the department
and across the width and breadth of this
country
altogether i served under five attorneys
general
appointed by four presidents
i know that some of you have notched up
plenty more
the department of justice has always
been a large part of the law has also
been a large part
of the lives of people who are close to
me my younger sister followed me to doj
where she served as a career attorney in
the civil division
more than 35 of my former law clerks
went on to serve at the justice
department
in both career and non-career positions
many of my closest friends are veterans
of the department
with both career and non-career service
for all of you and for me
public service is more than a job it is
a calling
all of you have chosen the department of
justice over other places
where you might have used your skills
and where you might have earned
a higher salary i am grateful beyond
words for your service to this country
all of us are united by our commitment
to the rule of law
and to seeking equal justice under law
we are united by our commitment to
protecting our country
as our oath says from all enemies
foreign and domestic and by our
commitment to enforcing our country's
laws
and to ensuring the civil rights and the
civil liberties of our people
the only way we can succeed and retain
the trust of the american people
is to adhere to the norms that have
become part of the dna
of every justice department employee
since edward levy's stint as the first
post
watergate attorney general as i said at
the announcement of my nomination
those norms require that like cases be
treated alike
that there not be one rule for democrats
and another for republicans
one rule for friends and another for
foes
one rule for the powerful and another
for the powerless
one rule for the rich and another for
the poor
or different rules depending upon one's
race
or ethnicity at his swearing-in
attorney general levy said quote if we
are to have
a government of laws and not of men then
it takes dedicated men and women to
accomplish this
through their zeal and determination
and also through fairness and
impartiality
and i know that this department always
has had such dedicated men and women
i too know that this department has
and always has had such dedicated people
to work with you once again
together we will show the american
people
by word and deed that the department of
justice pursues
equal justice and adheres to the rule of
law
thank you
you